i i don't think there's risk you know it
still comes down to having a good
football team and building a good roster
around uh
uh around everybody i mean it's there's
players here that are talented there's
rookies that are going to be coming in
that are talented and i the the
expectation is that they're one of 53
when it's all said and done and they've
they've all got to perform their best to
create a great football
and um so as far as pressure is
concerned there's no pressure on me it's
just there's always pressure there's
always pressure to put put together the
best football team we possibly can
regardless of who's playing so
um
very comfortable with uh every decision
that's made and it's our job to get him
to uh to put him in the best position to
be successful and that not just the
quarterback but but every single player
that takes the field the one thing that
i can attest to is
from a schematic standpoint
the scheme that lefleur is bringing is
is the best game in the world
robert sullivan talking about the
prospect of playing a rookie quarterback
you know peter 5 10 years ago
that would have raised some eyebrows
nowadays it's just a given with all
these great young quarterbacks coming
into the nfl and this clamoring to get
your franchise guy who's going to be
with you not just 5 or 10 years but
maybe if you're lucky 15 years maybe
longer than that i think that's another
impact of the tom brady career you get
that guy who is the guy
you've got that position taken care of
for a long time so you throw him into
the fray and you see what he can do
that's become the default now the days
of putting a guy on a bench
for a year or two they're not over it's
just the exception now the rule is if
you're going to use a first round pick
on a quarterback especially closer to
the top that guy's getting on the field
or you're going to draft somebody else
yeah you know mike i think i think over
the years two of the reasons why it has
become
so much more accepted that you're going
to play a quarterback early number one
in college football right now it used to
be
you know 40 years ago 30 years ago
that a college football team would play
a different game from an nfl team you
know and now the games are so much more
similar i think number two
is that quarterbacks most of them
are playing football
a lot more before they get to college
the seven on seven leagues andy dalton
told me a few years ago he goes you know
basically the red shirting need when you
get to pro football
is not nearly what it used to be because
we've already been playing in essence so
many of us
two seasons you know a fall season in
the spring season all through like
middle school high school
and so i think
that those two aspects really are
feeding into just the fact that
teams want players to play early and
they're significantly more ready to play
early do you remember last year on hard
knocks
when uh early on in training camp
you know you would watch hard knocks and
there would be pep hamilton the
quarterback coach of the chargers
and he would be talking to justin
herbert
and i mean he
and i'm paraphrasing because i don't
remember exactly where it was but it was
almost like dude get it together come on
let's go and he did he did get it
together in one training camp he proved
that he was ready
when that needle accidentally punctured
tyrod taylor's lung that he was more
than ready to play
and he played great and i think that is
what teams see
right now joe burrow last year if he
didn't get hurt joe burrow was going to
have a phenomenal year and he probably
would have been rookie of the year over
justin herbert at least it would have
been close
and so last year
two quarterbacks picked
of of the top three
two
of the three
were eminently ready to play football
opening day for an nfl team
and that's why i think you see all these
teams
scrambling to get to the top and mike
i'm in the process of doing research now
for my mock draft and i think it's
really possible that those five
quarterbacks all go in the top nine
picks whether it's a team
in that slot or whether it's going to be
traded because there are teams
talking to try to get up there and who
want those quarterbacks so they see what
we see
they see the potential
let's get your guy and start playing him
right now
and have him for a long long time and
have that position taken care of that
gives you job security as a coach you
think brett veach or andy reid are going
to be in any trouble during the duration
of patrick mahomes career i don't think
so and i think that same mindset applies
and you know rich eis and i were talking
about this earlier in the week because
he was a big proponent of kyle pitts to
the falcons potentially at four and
still is that could happen but my point
is you you take kyle pitts and you
scratch off that lottery ticket the
winner is capped at a hundred thousand
dollars the winner for a franchise
quarterback lottery ticket
that prize is a hell of a lot more than
that and that's not taking anything away
from kyle pitts but there's plenty of
great skill position players out there
and a great quarterback makes an average
skill position player into a better
skill position player it's the
quarterback that everyone wants it's the
quarterback that makes you relevant
every year that keeps putting you in the
playoffs and makes your team one of the
most desirable teams in the in the
entire league that's what these teams
are looking for and i think that's
that's why
this trend
of
rookie quarterbacks being drafted high
playing right away and then in turn when
we get to february and march veteran
quarterbacks constantly available teams
are going to be willing to cut the court
on a veteran guy because they're looking
for that franchise guy and unless you're
that franchise guy you're going to be at
risk of being not resigned potentially
cut potentially traded because they're
always looking for that guy that's going
to be the answer for a generation maybe
longer
mike i'm going to take a slight right
turn here and i'm going to just tell you
one other aspect of this as you were
talking that really hit me in the head
it's occurred to me all week as i've
been doing some research into the draft
it's occurred to me that there is one
team
that is really uh going to be negatively
impacted by the quarterback mania in
this draft and that is the chicago bears
and here's why the bears pick 20 it's
almost certain that none of those
quarterbacks are going to be around at
number 20. okay so what does that mean
it means that if the bears want any of
those quarterbacks and have to trade up
into say the top
seven or eight picks
in order to get one of those
quarterbacks what are they gonna have to
do well there is a template out there
and it's san francisco to miami you're
going to have to pay your 22nd and 2
2022
and 23 first round picks
suppose you're ryan pace and you go to
george mccaskey you know the owner
representative of the chicago bears the
chairman of the bears and you say to him
listen we can get trey lance but we got
to give up our uh first round picks in
22 and 23. what goes through george
mccaskey's head
if i were george mccaskey i would say
hmm
i i barely brought these guys back this
year
and now
if we go six and 11 this year
and both of these guys get fired you
know matt nagy and ryan pace then where
are we i got to hire a general manager
and a head coach and tell them oh by the
way
you know your welcome gift is that you
don't have a one in either of the next
two drafts
so
when that just occurred to me when you
were talking about that and and i just
say man the bears cannot catch a break
hey peter we've been on that issue to a
certain extent the idea that
it's in the interests of
ryan pace and matt nagy to trade future
assets
and move up and get a guy the presence
of whom gives them job security because
it will be more difficult to fire them
after this year because you're taking
the chance as a new gm new coach wants
nothing to do with that guy you gave up
all that stuff to go get you're right it
does make it harder for them i think
the team that picks one spot before
washington there's been some noise about
them moving up they're in a different
position different dynamic everyone's on
the same page but when you've got this
this pot seat this simmering hot seat it
it does complicate a desire to
potentially move up and also
look there's human nature at play here
pace and negi are smart enough to know
that they're more likely to come back in
2022 if they're developing this young
quarterback and also if they've traded
the first round pick next year and maybe
the year after that so yeah that's where
others have to get involved and make
sure they know what they're getting into
because it does make it very difficult
to make changes once you've mortgaged
the future the way that the bears would
have to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports